Another historic moment. This is perhaps outside, but perhaps within your,
uh, space of frameworks that you think about that just happened. Uh,
I guess a couple of weeks ago is, um,
I don't know if you're paying attention at all, is the,
the game stop and while she bets, uh,
so it's really fascinating. There's kind of a theme to this competition today.
Cause it's like neural networks. [inaudible]
, it's cool. How there's a large number of people in a distributed way. Almost having a kind of fun.
We're able to take on the powerful leads, uh,
lead hedge funds, centralized powers and overpower them. Uh,
do you have thoughts? I mean this whole saga.
I don't know enough about finance, but it was like the Elan, you know,
Robin hood guy, when they talk about that. Well,
Robin hood guy didn't know how to finance system marked. That was clear, right?
He was treating like the people who settled the transactions as a black box and
suddenly somebody called him up and say, Hey,
Blackbox calling you your transaction volume means you need to put out $3
billion right now. And he's like, I don't have $3 billion.
Like I don't even make any money on these trades.
Why do I have $3 billion while you're sponsoring a trade? So,
so there was a set of abstractions that, you know, I don't think either like,
like now we understand it. Like this happens in chip design.
Like you buy wafers from TSMC or Samsung or Intel.
And you know, they say it works like this and you do your design based on that.
And then chip comes back and it doesn't work.
And suddenly you started having to open the black boxes.
The transistors really work. Like they said, you know, what's the real issue.
So, so the
there's a whole set of things that created this opportunity and somebody spotted
it. Now, people spot these kinds of opportunities all the time.
So there's been flash crashes. There's been, you know, there's always short.
Squeezes are fairly regular. Every CEO I know,
hates the shorts because they're, they're manipulating,
they're trying to manipulate their stock in a way that they make money and,
you know, deprive value from both the company on the investors.
So the fact that so many stocks were so short,
it's hilarious that this hasn't happened before. I don't know why.
And I don't actually know why some serious hedge funds didn't do it to other
hedge funds. And some of the hedge funds actually made a lot of money on this.
So my guess is we know 5% of what really happened.
And a lot of the players don't know what happened and people probably made the
most money. Aren't the people that they're talking about. Yeah. That's okay.
Do you think there was something, uh, I mean, this is, this is the cool kind of,
uh, Ilan, uh,
you're the same kind of conversationalist,
which is like first principles questions of like, what the hell happened.
Uh, just very basic questions of like, was there something shady going on? Uh,
what, you know, who are the parties involved?
This is the basic questions that everybody wants to know about.
Yeah. So like we're in a very competitive hyper competitive world, right?
But transactions like buying sewing soccer is a trust event. You know,
I trust the company representing themselves properly. You know,
I bought the stock because I think it's going to go up.
I trust that the regulations are solid now, inside of that,
there's all kinds of places where, you know, humans over trust.
And you know, this, this expose,
let's say some weak points in the system.
I don't know if that's going to get corrected. I don't know.
I don't know if we have close to the real story. My,
my suspicion is we don't and listen to that guy.
You look a little wide-eyed about it. And then he did this and then he did that.
And I was like, Hmm, I think he should know more about your business than that.
But again, there's many businesses when like this layer is really stable.
You stop paying attention to it.
You pay attention to the stuff that's bugging you or new, right?
You don't pay attention to the stuff that just seems to work all the time.
You just, you know, sky is blue every day, California and where what's wild,
know it rains. And it was like, what do we do?
Somebody go bring in the lawn furniture. You know, like it's getting wet,
it's getting wet. I was blue for a hundred days. And now it's, you know,
so.
Part of the problem here with Vlad, this, the CEO of Robin hood is as a scaling.
Cause it would have been talking about is there's a lot of unexpected
things that happen with the scaling and you have to be,
I think the scaling forces you to then return to the fundamentals.
Well, it's interesting because when you buy and sell stocks, the scaling is,
you know, the stocks only move in a certain range. And if you buy a stock,
you can only lose that amount of money. On the short, short market.
You can lose a lot more than you can benefit. Like it has, it has a weird cost,
you know, cost function or whatever the right word for that is.
So he was trading in a market or he wasn't actually capitalized for the
downside. If it got outside a certain range. Now,
whether something nefarious has happened, I have no idea. But at some point the,
uh, the financial risk to both him and his customers was way outside of his
financial capacity and his understanding how the system work was clearly
weak or, uh, or he didn't represent himself. I, you know,
I don't know the person, then I listened to them and it could have been,
the surprise question was like, these guys called him. No,
it sounded like he was treating stuff as a black box. Maybe he shouldn't have,
but maybe he has a whole pilot expert somewhere else. And it was going on.
I don't, I don't know. Yeah.
I mean, this is, uh,
this is one of the qualities of a good leader is under fire.
You have to perform. And that means to think clearly and to speak clearly.
And he dropped the ball on those things cause and understand the problem
quickly,
learn and understand the problem at like at the like basic level,
like what the hell happened.
And my guess is, you know,
at some level it was amateur is trading against, you know,
experts slash insiders slash people with special information outside is
insiders. Yeah. And the insiders, you know,
my guess is the next time this happens. We'll make money on it.
The insiders always went.
Well. They have more tools and more incentive. I mean, this always happens.
Like the outsiders are doing this for fun. The insiders are doing this 24 seven.
Numbers in the outsiders. This is an interesting thing.
There's numbers on the insiders too. Like kinda numbers,
different kind of numbers.
But this could be a new era because I don't know,
at least I didn't expect that a bunch of Redditers could, you know, there's a,
you know, millions of people can get to the next one. Won't be a surprise.
But don't you think the, the,
the crowd that people are planning the next attack.
We'll see, but it has to be a surprise. Can't be the same game
as like, it could be,
there's a very large number of games to play and they can be told about it.
I don't know. I'm not an expert.
Right. That's a good question. How about the space of games?
How restricted is it?
Yeah. And the system is so complicated. It could be relatively unrestricted.
And also like during the last couple of financial crashes, you know,
what set it off was, you know, sets of derivative events where, you know,
that seemed Todd leaves, you know, thing is there,
you're there trying to lower volatility in the short run,
but creating tail events and systems always evolve towards that.
And then you always crash.
Like the gas curve is the star low ramp
plateau crash. It's a hundred percent effective.
In the long run.